hey everyone it's Yara shahini and here
are my recommendations for you this week
because this is my three to go something
that'll get your heart pumping is cliche
but trying something new I know for me
it does not matter how big or small said
new adventure is having time hanging out
with a new friend to reading a new book
you know it just brings new energy into
your life something that'll make you
feel cozy and soft are fuzzy socks
people relegate fuzzy socks to bedtime
but I've been wearing them under every
shoe especially since it's a little
colder out oh my goodness it's like my
little secret that makes me so happy
throughout the day boots fuzzy socks
heels fuzzy socks something that'll
expand your horizons is listening to
podcasts that's my favorite way to not
only learn more about things I already
care about but honestly I go to the NPR
one app hit Shuffle and it'll take me to
a new subject that I have learned
nothing about and it's such a cool
natural way to just explore the world
around you without having to go anywhere
and those are my Wrecks for you to have
a wonderful week bye